if you want to approach a woman just
treat her like a person first and a
person that you want to [ __ ] second
hi I'm Rachel bloom and today I'm going
to teach you how to not be that guy I
love men that are great I'm married to
one
but there are some mannerisms that some
men have that if they fixed they'd be
better people are just guys but people
let's talk about I generally don't like
people who rely on trite catchphrases to
be their own catchphrase and so anyone
who's like I got swag BAE and like
that's their catchphrase it's like
that's not your catchphrase that's the
world's those are the world's terms you
can say swag I just if you sit a lot
okay I think so many of these tips are
in context and what we're dancing around
is the subject of social EQ just having
an awareness of how you come off and how
you treat other people it's something
that you just have to learn I recommend
a therapy ultimately get yourself into
therapy any unpleasant odor emanating
from you is just gonna be not only a
turn-off romantically but also a
turn-off just as your friend I have some
guys better my friends who have a patio
and really bad breath it's just not
great to be around
I know it's your animal smell but
there's also something you can do about
it coupon deodorant there are so many
ways you can present yourself to the
world and not offend people with your
stench just bathe every morning shower
every morning don't bathe that's well
men should shower every morning if your
hygiene is really bad there's a lack of
self respect there that if I see how
load think of himself oh then what are
you gonna think of me if you have a lot
of dirt under your nails I get dirt
under my nails life is hard
that's
a dirt under your nails happened are you
burying the body what's going on I think
guys should get manicures and pedicures
and I think it's gendered [ __ ] that
it's seen as something ladylike every
one has nails manis and pedis feel
amazing you don't have to get your nails
painted you could just get them trimmed
and it'll show you you're confident who
you are as a man you get a man guys who
don't wash your hands after using the
bathroom look I get it you when you guys
pee you sometimes I guess just let your
dick fall out of your pants and then you
go like that I guess you don't touch
your penis and then when I say oh did
you I mean I won't ask guys if they
touch their penis regularly but okay so
sometimes guys go pee and they think
we'll all I did was touch my dick I
didn't touch the people if nothing else
for the optics just wash your [ __ ]
hands dude I think we should publicly
shame people who don't wash their hands
if you've just left the restroom and you
haven't turned the faucet on an alarm
should go off and we should shame you
like Cersei Lannister and Game of
Thrones he walks through the streets and
people shout shame and they throw [ __ ]
at her you know I have some sympathy for
manspreading because I've talked to my
lovely husband about this a lot and you
have these terrible things called balls
truly awful horrible design so I get it
I get that you have to spread however
that's not my fault I think that you can
spread to a point if you are blocking a
seat though just in in a little bit I
think there's a happy medium between
crossing like a lady and letting the
ball sack air out I just find that happy
medium
the cat calling thing I mean I get it
testosterone makes you want to [ __ ]
everything you see but when you cat fall
it feels like someone's touching you in
an inappropriate place and you have not
asked for it
and it makes you feel naked even if
you're wearing a blow-up set if you see
another man cat call why don't you step
in and stop them because women there's
only so much you can do the one time I
talk back to a cat caller
I almost got beaten up if I speak up for
another woman the two of us might but if
you're a dude you might actually listen
to you and you can do it like a do I'd
be like brah you want to get [ __ ]
that's not the way or whatever however
men talk to each other I don't know the
men who tell women to smile more what
you're basically saying is hey right now
I want a picture [ __ ] you but I can't
quite get there so can you help me out
with a smile ah there it is now I can
come out to it don't be the guy who
calls women you don't know sweetie
or cutie if a woman's getting mad and
you try to diminish her by saying oh
you're cute when you're mad or calm down
sweetie I hate you it's not great when
women do it but most of the time when
it's coming from a man to a woman it's
kind of gross unless there are a
thousand years old and they're from a
different time I think that we've
learned a lot her romantic buddies to be
super persistent when a woman doesn't
like you that kind of Sam and I am
equality it's not gonna just happen in a
bar you're not gonna fire a woman's
interest with an eggy one-liner and if
woman rejects you just leave don't leave
the bar I mean ideally leave the bar but
move on she's not interested so these
were just some tips to help you be a
better guy specifically men who want to
sleep and interact with women obviously
came in have other etiquette things some
of this applies to game into
we're all just people life is hard I
hope